hey this is presh talwalker
start with the square whose side length
is equal to one unit
construct four congruent right triangles
as shown where each right triangle's
hypotenuse is a side of the square and
the entire large square is divided into
these four triangles plus a square in
the center
inside of each triangle inscribe a
circle
also inscribe a circle in the square in
the center
now if these five circles are equal to
each other what is the radius of each
circle equal to
I think Mikhail from Norway and surov
for the suggestion
this problem was inspired by a Japanese
sangaku
which were mathematical problems and
theorems that were offered in temples in
Japan during the Edo period
they were engraved on wood they were
very beautiful
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
foreign
there are many many ways to solve this
problem and for the purposes of this
video I'm just going to present one
solution but I'm sure people will come
up with other ways to solve the problem
please share them in the comments
so here's one way to solve it
let's say that the length of this
tangent is equal to a
now if we take the corresponding
triangle in the bottom side of the
square this tangent will also have the
same length so it will be a length equal
to a
now if we construct this tangent
the two tangents will have the same
length so this length will also be equal
to a
now we know the square in the center has
a circle with the radius that's equal to
R
so the diameter of the circle will be 2R
and that will be the side length of the
square
so we know that half of the length of
the square will be equal to R
now by the principle of equal tangents
this length over here will also be equal
to R
if we extend the side of the square this
will also be equal to R
now we can see in this bottom triangle
the small side has a side length that's
equal to a plus r
so if we take the triangle on the left
side of the square the small side will
also have a length that's equal to a
plus r
so this length will be equal to a plus r
minus a so this will be equal to R
now we have one more thing to consider
let's take a look at the length of this
tangent
it will exactly be the same length as
this tangent
so the upper tangent has a length a plus
2R so this length will be a plus 2R
so now we know the length of all the
sides of this triangle so let's just
focus on that
so let me just isolate this triangle and
let me put in the side lengths the short
side is a plus r and the hypotenuse is
2A plus 2R because we have a plus 2R
plus a
now we can Factor this as equal to 2
multiplied by a plus r but we know a
plus r is the side length of the short
side
so we have a right triangle where the
hypotenuse is twice the length of the
short leg so this must be a 30 60 90
right triangle
now we know the remaining side is equal
to a plus r plus r plus r which is a
plus 3r finally the hypotenuse of this
right triangle is exactly the side
length of the square so it will be equal
to one
so now let's just focus on this 30 60 90
right triangle
in a 30-60-90 right triangle if the
hypotenuse has a length equal to one the
shorter leg is equal to one-half and the
longer leg is equal to root three over
two
so in this triangle the shorter leg is
equal to a plus r so we have a plus r is
equal to one-half
then the longer leg is equal to a plus
3r so that's equal to root 3 over 2.
so now if we subtract one equation from
the other we can eliminate the a
variable and this will give us that 2R
is equal to root 3 minus 1 all over two
dividing both sides by 2 gives that R is
equal to root 3 minus one all over 4
which is approximately equal to
0.183 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]